[Musik]
und das ist unser berühmtes Ingwer
Kartoffelpüree und da habe ich nur ein
räumliche über Cocktailsauce und Winter
Nachschlag braucht sie überhaupt kein
Problem 5 Liter Kanister draußen in der
Küche das sieht aber gut aus und so viel
um Gottes Willen wie soll man das alles
essen wir in der Sterneküche empfehlen
da Messung Gabel habe
also wir nehmen Pizza eine Gabel und ein
halbes Hänsel und dann schneidet man
doch so am Knochen gutes gelegt ist und
dann hat man einen Hitler
Achtung heiß aber das geht doch nicht
das geht ja überhaupt nicht bei dem
Tempo der Hocker die zwei Depp mir in
der Früh um also aufpassen das geht so
man nimmt den hendlhaxen in Hand und
Donner beißt man halt einfach nee
lassen sie meinen Schenkel los
[Musik]
die muss man nämlich schälen so dann
tanzen knusprig schmecken aber trotzdem
so langsam
bitte schön
genau wir gehen
momentan kein Problem ich zeig's Ihnen
dieses gar nicht schwer
150 so danke schön vielen herzlichen
Dank für Ihre Besucher
geht aber wirklich
[Musik]